JAMES GRIME: There are people
out there who want to change
the way that you count.
They want to change the world so
that we stop counting using
10 symbols and start counting
using 12 symbols.
I love them.
I think these guys are great.
Let's talk about what
we know so far.
So, the way we count is
the decimal system.
It uses 10 symbols.
So, let's just write those
out, first of all.
0, 1, 2, 8, 9.
Once we get to this point, we
start to have to make our
numbers using combinations of
the symbols we've already got.
12, 13, 14, 22, 23.
Now, if we had been born with
six fingers on each hand, then
we would have 12 fingers, and
maybe we would have started
using something called the
dozenal system where it's
based on 12 symbols.
And there are some people out
there who think this is the
system we should be using.
They think we should have six
fingers on each hand.
They're disappointed we don't
have six fingers on each hand,
because they think it's a much
easier way to count.
So first of all, if we're going
to use 12 symbols, I
need two extra.
Let's have a look at
what they suggest.
For 10, we we're going to
have a symbol like this.
That's called dek.
And for 11, we're going to have
a symbol like this, which
is called el.
So now it reads 0, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, dek, el.
This would be 12.
In fact, they say do.
So this is do, do 1, do 2, do 3,
do 4, do 5, do 6, do 7, do
8, do 9, do dek, and do el.
So, do el would be
12 and 11 more.
So that's 23, and then
you keep counting.
2 do is 24, so 2 do.
Two do 1, 2 do 3, 2
do 4, and so on.
Just like decimal
system, really.
It's the exact same idea.
There's no difference between
the dozenal system and the
decimal system.
That would be 3 do, this
would be 4 do.
You keep going and you would get
9 do, then you would get
dek do, el do, and then
you'd get do do.
do do.
12 12s.
12 12s, that's 144,
12 12s, or gross.
So if we write that out, 12 12s
will be written like this.
It's 144, or gross, or gro
So that would be a gro.
Something like this
would be a mo.
So if we take this year, it's
2012, which is a good year to
pick, since we were
talking about 12.
So if we took the year 2012,
in the dozenal system, it's
written like this.
That is mo gro el 8.
That's the current year if
you count in base 12.
Now, there is a reason
why these guys want
to count this way.
Because they say it's going to
make arithmetic much easier.
I want to make this clear.
For serious maths, this system
would not make any difference.
But for day to day life, for
your regular shopping, these
guys reckon that this 12 system
would make life much
easier because of the number
of factors that 12 has.
So 10 has--
let's see.
How many factors does it have?
It has 1.
10 has 2, 5, and 10 itself.
But 12 has much more factors.
It has 1, it has 2, it has
3, it has 4, it has 6,
and it has 12 itself.
The reason this is useful is
it will make calculations
using thirds and quarters
much easier
than they are in decimal.
Let's do something like
a 4 times table.
If we did that in decimal,
it would look like this.
OK, it's 4, and then 2 times 4
is 8, 3 times 4 is 12, 4 times
4 is 16, 5 times 4 is 20.
If we did it with the dozenal
system, then it would have 4,
and we would have 8, then we
would have do, which is their
word for 12.
Then we would have do 4, do
8, 2 do, 2 do 4, 2 do 8,
3 do, and so on.
This pattern is a much easier
pattern to teach children.
4, 8, 0, 4, 8, 0, 4, 8, 0.
The patterns are much
easier to see.
But the real strength of it is
when you start dividing.
If we wanted something like 1/3,
you know in decimal that
this is 0.3333, it goes on
forever, which is fairly ugly.
But in the dozenal system, it
suddenly becomes really nice.
If I want to write 1/3,
that'd be 4 out of do.
4/12 is 1/3.
4 out of do, which
is equal to 0.4.
1/3 written in this
system is 0.4.
It's not something that
goes on forever.
That's the sort of thing
that decimal does.
It's horrible.
In dozenal, it doesn't happen.
Let's do something else.
Let's do a quarter.
A quarter of 12, a quarter of
do, is 3 out of do, which
would be 0.3.
1/2 would be 6 out of
do, which is 0.6.
If you want to do 1/6, that
would be 2 out of
do, which is 0.2.
Suddenly, all these become
much simpler.
You can see now why
they like it.
Suddenly, all those horrible
things that happen in decimal
don't happen in dozenal.
If we had been born with six
fingers on each hand and this
is the system we have learnt,
and then I came to you and
said, no, I've got an idea,
let's not use base 12, let's
use base 10, you would
laugh in my face.
Why would you use base 10?
It's not as good.
Now, naturally, we actually
count in twelves, and
historically, weights and
measures were in twelves.
So you would have
feet and inches.
12 inches to a foot.
And currency was counted in
twelves as well, because it
was naturally made dividing by
half, dividing by thirds, and
dividing by quarters
and sixths.
Much more easy and much more
practical, and that's the
system we had.
Then in the French Revolution,
the French got obsessed with
decimalizing everything.
They wanted to make weights and
measures easier to use, so
they wanted to decimalize it,
divide it into 100 because we
use the decimal system.
Now, they had a choice.
They could have decimalized
everything, or they could have
changed the way we counted
from 10 to 12.
If they had done that, they
could have kept all the
weights and measures the same
and all the calculations would
have been as easy to do
in dozenal as they
are today in decimal.
Now, they chose to make things
metric and keep the system.
Maybe they made the
wrong choice.
In fact, in the French
Revolution, they went so mad
with decimalization that they
had a decimal week, they had a
decimal calendar, and a
decimal clock as well.
They did that for a few years.
Didn't take off.
BRADY HARAN: What would pi be?
Would pi be the same?
JAMES GRIME: So, if we're
talking about serious maths,
something like pi, it would look
a lot different, and it
would involve these dek symbols
and el symbols.
And if we look at it, it looks
weird and unusual.
But if you were born with this
system, it would be fine.
It would be normal.
There's no significant
difference in the mathematics.
The real difference this would
make would be to just your
regular life.
It might make arithmetic easier
for children as well.
BRADY HARAN: But the one thing,
I guess, people are
going to say is, when you're
very small and learning about
numbers, your fingers and your
hands are a really useful
learning aid.
You'd be taking that away from
children right at the start.
JAMES GRIME: Well, to answer
that, there are some cultures
that still use base 12.
And what they do is
they count on the
segments of your fingers.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, dek, el, do.
Just as easy to use.
MATT PARKER: How many
hours do you want?
So the next one, let's say we
did 3 to the power of, to the
power of, arrow, arrow, arrow,
or whatever you want
to call this, 3.
That is equivalent to 3 to the
double to the double to the 3.